is there another country that's coming
along with boron that's like that P you
don't you don't think about you know you
think of it as I mean especially growing
up in America
think of it as an American kind of sport
is that true is that know she we got
Canada Australia Brazil Mexico everyone
has the PBR Association there and they
ride in it but the toughest ones are the
Brazilians they're unbelievable they
have to man it's their life like they
leave everything you know you think
about it Brazil's not a really they're
not a really rich country yeah a lot of
these guys have grown up with nothing
and so they leave home they come over
here and it's like this is all they do
so you see a bunch of Brazilians living
in the same little circle they get up
they worked out they practice they they
eat together they do everything together
they don't have all the distractions of
the rest of the world that you know like
just seeing our families and everything
that we do normally oh yeah they don't
have it so they're laser focused they're
so good man there's something there's a
there's a special value in having that
struggle and having that extra chip that
you can't you can't imitate it like even
as I find as I get a little more
comfortable like started making some
money this past year it's hard to go
back to the it's hard to get that same
mentality of when you have nothing yeah
when everything is on the line you know
when you have to stay like it's like a
chip inside of yourself that you can't
it's hard to replicate it yeah you know
I think it's that way with anything
though like like once you see a certain
level like even day-to-day like if I
have a really good Monday I don't want
to x' day to suck you know because then
I feel like the week's wasted so it's
like you got to maintain this level
that's why they always say like you know
people that are superstars are usually
the loneliest people because they push
their self to this level and it's so
hard to come back down you know what I
mean yeah and so I see that with these
guys like they're constantly pushing
themselves and if they buck off one bull
it like ruins their week yeah and they
got to forget about it and turn around
because they got to do it again tomorrow
if you have a shitty rod in the first
rod right so Friday you don't have a
good rod they call it a rod what are
they kept yeah you have a tough ride at
the first the first go do you have a
chance in that Saturday to make it back
up and to get into Sunday yep so this
events a little different from normal
they take the top 25 into the day - so
you
you're outside of the top 25 and you
buck off your weekends done whereas I'm
second right now and I'm almost
guaranteed to ride tomorrow but on a
regular weekend you're guaranteed to so
if you suck Friday you better forget
that [ __ ] and just push it aside because
you got another one Saturday and you got
to make the most of it then what does it
do to your mentality if you have a tough
Friday does it affect it or are you able
to kind of scrap and just get right in
that's the thing it's everyone it's 90%
mental and boy and you can put in all
that work and it's not gonna matter if
you get to the boron and you see your
bowl you're like oh man I don't like the
looks of him then you're screwed you
just gotta be positive about everything
even if you buck off you got to be like
well I got tomorrow I got a good bowl
even if he's not good I'm gonna make him
good when you when the shoot when they
open the gate
this is in is hitting me man good stuff
yeah dude I remember the first time I
ever did chewing tobacco it's like
cherry Scholl or something and I did
like a half a can I was trying to show
my buddy up right and I didn't know
anything about it dude and I had like
I'm a whole mouth was full of it how old
were you I was probably about 14 really
and my buddies took his mom's car we
were going out we were partying you know
we weren't really we're just driving
around but and I vomited out of the
front window out of the passenger side
yeah and he's like dude you can't sit up
there anymore but you got to sit in the
back I vomit out of both of the back
windows oh yeah and so on the side of
the car we went and we hung out at night
and then we went and parked the car in
the morning his mom thought he'd been
partying with a whole group of people
vomit on the window and they didn't
believe it I was just dealing he just
thought he wasn't do it real well yeah
my first time still don't believe to
this day she's like there's no way one
child vomited out of three windows my
first tobacco I was to my dad left it
laying there and I thought it would be a
good idea to just put it in my mouth
take a drink whatever it was not a good
idea puked came out both ends dad took
me outside garden hosed me off ran
around naked the rest of the day pretty
successful day mom still hazy were you 2
or 22 yeah let's be anyways
it was in college for watching that
video right there that was a beautiful
little segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe subscribe